greetings replicant ID number nx9 637
zero point for your recent retirement
has been cited for forensic memory
review by the Los Angeles Police
Department memory analysis will take
place in a Wallace corporation memory
reconstruction facility under my hollow
supervision as a Joyetech model i am
engineer to ensure the security of your
data you will be asked to recall the
memory in question using the Stelling
scanner i will extract this memory from
your mind for holographic viewing and
analysis as a replicant your memories
are the property of the Wallace
corporation licensed to the Los Angeles
Police Department interference in this
process will lead to immediate
retirement do not speak during the
memory extraction and analysis follow
all instructions carefully a proper
response to the Stelling scanner can
cause permanent damage to memories and
neural tissue don't worry the process is
painless provided you follow all of the
instructions
I'll see you shortly
I've never met a blade runner before
memory extraction in progress memory
extraction complete extracted memory
ready to view go ahead have a look
I assume this looks familiar
you chased a replicant through Vegas bar
you chased him to an alley
and then when you cornered him what is
this what are you doing I'm no replicant
not exactly by the book I could use a
little more data here stay still I'll
turn the scanner back on now stay
focused on the perpetrator please now
maintain that focus for me what's going
on
who do you think you are
something's wrong you're in a different
memory standard procedure for retirement
debrief is that you tell us if you know
the replicant you know that holding two
memories in your mind at once produces
dissonance and interferes with a stellar
memory transfer fortunately I was able
to save both memories to my system but
the interference means that the memories
have been erased from your mind so you
have a memory of this replicant
attacking you but then you met him again
today and retired him and you didn't
follow procedure you didn't even check
for a replicant ID you just retired him
which is totally against your training
and your genetic profile something does
seem off here I have enough data to
reconstruct your memory let's go in and
take a look
welcome to your memory that memo will
let you control the simulation to move
around point the memo where you want to
go and push the control stick forward
it's right up come meet me over here to
teleport aim at the blue node and press
forward on the control stick spin the
control stick to change your perspective
when you complete good let's get a
closer look
do you want to know what you are thought
we'd skinjob come ye heavy states at
night you your father's spirit right
soundings baleful birth anine my song I
noticed something strange over here not
that it wasn't all strange come have a
look
that's reflected light do you see a
light up there we call this a flaw it's
a mistake the memory makers didn't catch
it means that this memory is definitely
an implant I must have been made at an
older system back then implants were
based on actual human memories and had
to be edited so if there's a reflection
on the ground they edited the ceiling
your memo can revert the memory to what
it was before they changed it start by
scanning the ceiling just point your
memo up and pull the trigger to scan the
object you'll need to pull the trigger
to modify the object and reveal what was
originally in its place you will press
and pull the
or next button by your thumbs then point
the beam directly data restoration
complete I knew it this memory was
edited and implanted inside your
subconscious mind while the security got
to the corpse before LAPD got there I'll
check in but in the meantime use your
memo to reveal more of the original
scene don't worry
we made you and will take care of you
Wow identify
original image restorer flaw located
data restoration complete
long detected law identified original
image restoring long detected data
restoration complete I've got news for
you someone put a lot of effort into
altering this memory
I spoke with security we have bad news
the escaped replicant the man you killed
was a human
cigar space required encoded whoever
that is created all of this so you would
hate and fear that man's face it looked
like it worked
a replicant later on our retiring human
could bring on another prohibition and
the end of the Wallace corporation we
want to help you while the security will
make sure that the body is lost in
transit but LAPD will requisition your
memory of the retirement but since this
is the only copy of the event we can
make a few changes
what is this what are you doing I'm no
replicant you did try to warn you
hey I found a witness come up here there
he is
ooh big it's nice time but it does give
the police a way to find him you're
lucky we're not offworld down here no
one's gonna stick their neck out over
just one little homicide but if the cops
can identify any of these people they
will start knocking on doors I've
updated your memo
what you changed here will be edited
permanently with no flaws for the police
to find give it a try on that graffiti
scam contains personal data federal ID
records were lost in the blackout but
I'll double-check any possible witnesses
against LAPD's criminal files in the
meantime use your memo to edit anything
the police might use to find a name or
address I guess it's a good thing you're
a play runner
[Music]
there were probably more witnesses to
find them teleport down into the alley
and go out to the street
personal information detected data
alteration complete
personal data identified a randomized
data placed citizen identified
data replacement is completed
scam contains personal data
random data malee place go back to the
alley
there you are good news no one here has
a criminal record but the police did ask
to review this memory and there's one
detail we can't forget there no
replicant ID good then your friends in
the Wallace corporation I made a record
for him in our replicant database give
him his numbers
personal information detected with a
body gun Donkin say he wasn't a
replicant
who was this guy
it's not much personal data here huh
no did you find anything interesting
Osbert analyzed incoming video call
[Music]
I'm sure you recognize me under Wallace
come forward did you not recognize me
Richards whom you killed was a
productive employee but developed the
moral objections of a lesser mind I had
planned for this within you and any
replicant Bladerunner are a series of
memories in which you are beaten
humiliated by individuals who might
threaten this company's future today
Richards betrayed me I called you and
you exceeded every expectation when you
killed
Tyrel claimed his primitives were more
human than human but nothing is more
human than violence without reason
something about this one is exceptional
we will free you from your fears in
order to understand how you came to feel
them I envy you and I lament that the
final world will arrive without you in
it
you